rick and morty which is an emmy
award-winning
animated comedy series uh getting ready
for their season five premiere
this sunday june 20th and one of the
stars
summer smith is a fan of our show and
she wanted to pop in
and say hello summer how are you hi
hi no i'm i'm doing really really good
um thanks ernie for
having me on the show it's just so nice
to be here um
you know i'm really disappointed that
you guys didn't tell me that i needed to
wear like a blue gray
plaid suit on the show though so like
i would have been way more prepared but
you guys kind of dropped the ball but
whatever it's fine you know i was kind
of nervous coming because
i don't know it's like i'm a teenager
and then
corporate synergy and it's like kind of
inauthentic
but like you know they told me that i
could talk to shaq which is super cool
and that if i did a really really good
job on this interview that i would also
be able to
um be featured on the new kelly clarkson
show and that's kind of what my angle is
but you know
i'm glad i got to be on well you have an
opportunity right here to talk to shaq
if you've got
something on your mind um
do you like space yes i love bass
and i love you also you do a wonderful
space
oh space i thought you said bass yes i
love space
kenny you have you have a question for
summer summer
uh yeah is your name uh are you named
after anyone or
is this just uh the months or that's the
reason why
how did summer become your name when
your parents gave it to you is there a
reason when they gave it to me
yeah it was a reason it's a very very
basic
name you know for a teenage girl so i
think that's why
they named me that you're anything but
basic i will say oh
oh thank you i appreciate that um i'm
just wondering like
if you could would you guys come visit
us sometime in the rick and morty verse
like is anyone up for that chuck i'm not
opposed to the rick and morty verse but
i got a question for you
what kind of music what kind of music
are the high school kids listening to
these days um high school kids listen to
like
juice world and like little nasdaq i'm
pretty sure
maybe ash nico she's pretty cool i like
her she's
a feminist we we rock we rock together
you guys have no idea what i'm talking
about juice
[Music]
what you got in store for season five
that you can share with us without
giving too much away
too much away okay well there's a lot of
family-centric episodes
where the family does some really cool
stuff together there's an episode that
like i don't
know if i would show a child
it probably a little bit
too mature that's maybe why it's on
adult swim
probably exactly exactly so there's like
definitely some mature audience stuff
going down
um and then uh i don't know it's gonna
be fun it's like a
crazy show if you haven't seen it then
i don't know where you've been living
for the last 10 years because we you
invited us you invited us on the show
didn't you
i did i did you have to come visit us i
mean just come like to a realm or
a dimension or like c137 or any of the
other ones that exist
well he's always in it anyway charles is
in that space anyway so he
it's very helpful
yeah you guys kind of put the fun and
dysfunctional don't you uh especially if
your grandfather
is somebody who travels through space
and is a little bit psychopathic but
you know we don't talk about that side
of it because like narcissism
is a little bit celebrated in our family
you know because if you have like a
dream
you got to just go for it no matter who
can get in your way um
and if they get in your way you just
like you just jump ship to another
universe and it's fine
rick and morty season premiere season 5
premiere on
sunday june the 20th uh
summer it's been it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for joining
us on inside
yes thank you so much for having me love
you summer love you summer
thank you so much okay thank you and
uh and on that note that's a wrapper
inside the nba presented
by kia